good afternoon I'm Rachel Maddow The
Daily wire has just broken some news
this has just come out this is
incredible
Democrats fact-free demagoguery of
illegal alien shelters is not woo it's
not it's not oh can we can we put up a
graphic of all this do we have it
Democrats fact-free demagoguery of
illegal alien shelters is not working
because the Obama administration did
exactly the same thing and nobody cared
CNN and MSNBC and fake Republican pundit
strategists are oh I'm gonna have to
hand this off I'm sorry I'm sorry that
does this for us tonight we'll see you
again tomorrow now it is time for the
Michael Knowles Show with Michael
Knowles
[Music]
wow that was a really powerful opening
from Rachel Maddow that was a really hmm
really good stuff we're gonna get to
more of that we're gonna have to play
that again in a second that was really
powerful
this totally contrived the contrived
immigration issue by the way is already
having major ramifications for the
Republican Party the GOP has lost
another fake Republican from the ranks
Steve Schmidt we're gonna analyze that
later then we're going to talk about
Chesterton's fence and how Chesterton's
fence is getting ten feet higher finally
we're gonna bring on Derek Hunter he is
the author of the new book outrage
incorporated how the liberal media
ruined science journalism and Hollywood
he'll become very quickly okay before we
get before we get to my doppleganger
isn't it
look how hard I work for you I got to
jump over to MSNBC then I got to come
back here and do this show all in a
day's work I got a cry I got a recover
before if we get to playing that again
we have to thank Lending Club make a
little money honey these guys are so so
good and I can attest a Lending Club and
you know sometimes you're in a pinch and
you need a little bit of money this
happens in life for decades credit cards
have been telling us buy it now pay for
it later with interest despite your best
intentions what happens that interest
gets out of control very fast with
Lending Club you can consolidate your
debt you can pay off credit cards with
one fixed payment
don't let these high interest credit
cards destroy your financial future
since 2007 Lending Club has helped
millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards just
go to Lending Club com tell them about
yourself how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you if
you are approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days this
is really important when bent doesn't
pay me it's really good to have the
opportunity to get a little money and
keep living you know when I was younger
through a series of unfortunate events I
inherited my house and those houses are
money pits something is always going
wrong at the worst moment when your bank
accounts low you know the roof starts
leaking the water
or whatever use the tools available to
you Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform over 35
billion billion with a B in loans issued
go to Lending Club comm / Knowles kano
wles check your rate in minutes borrow
up to $40,000 that's Lending Club comm /
Knowles KO wles
borrow up to $40,000 that's
approximately 40,000 times my annual
salary from Ben Shapiro Lending Club
comm / Knowles can o wles all loans made
by web bank member FDIC Equal Housing
lender ok we're gonna have to play
Rachel again because it was so moving
that was so emotional can we cut back to
my doppelganger on MSNBC the AP has just
broken some new news this has just come
out from The Associated Press this is
incredible
Trump administration officials have been
sending babies and other young children
Oh - at least three
hmm put up the graphic of this thank you
could we have it no three tender age
shelters in South Texas lawyers and
medical providers just think I'm gonna
have to hand this off yeah sorry that
does the first night we'll see again
tomorrow no it is time for the last word
lawrence O'Donnell where he is live in
Brownsville Texas
thank you very much Rachel we just got
word you know I hate to criticize my
twin here I hate to attack family that
is one of the worst performances I have
ever seen as an actor I am listen I've
been in these indie movies and little
things I'm not saying that you know I've
been in the great movies of all time or
Citizen Kane every performance I've done
is a Sidney Poitier compared to what she
just did on MSNBC it was so unbelievable
it just wasn't incredible performance
but I don't know maybe that's why she
makes more money than me she's at least
willing to go out there and humiliate
herself and pretend to cry over this
totally contrived issue why is this a
totally contrived issue why because
they've really been ringing this one for
all it's worth out there on the left
even though we present them with facts
don't we so then she says oh gosh oh oh
oh no it's so awful well she wasn't
shedding those tears when Barack Obama
was doing exactly the same thing was she
unfortunately for the I you know someone
I think was Ann Coulter said that the
immigrant children are crisis actors I'm
not saying that but Rachel Maddow
definitely is a crisis actor because
that it just isn't true she wasn't
crying when Barack Obama was doing these
things under the Obama administration
and we have the photos to prove it folks
Barack Obama put these kids in shelters
twice as many kids as Donald Trump has
you saw all those photos of kids
sleeping under sinks packed you know a
bunch of them in a room wrapped up in
those little tin foil blankets that they
give you on marathons that make you look
like a twice baked potato there all of
these kids piled on top of one another
during the Obama administration not a
peep from Rachel Maddow not a nary a
tear fell from her face isn't that
luckily for us now we've got the proper
vessel so when they start pouring we can
start sipping them and they're all
delicious but that you know
handcuffed you would even see some
photos under the Obama administration it
would say juvenile holding cell so just
in case it wasn't clear the Democrats
tried to spin it these are holding cells
for children they even had some that
said female juvenile holding cell which
is really the great outrage of the Obama
administration because he was assuming
people's gender how outrageous I mean
that's the worst crime of all isn't it I
can't believe the intersectional left
didn't raise a ruckus about that what
else in the Obama administration well
there was an immigrant illegal alien
Nancy Luna who sued for wrongful death
sued the Obama administration in 2014
for the wrongful death of her husband
because he had type 2 diabetes he was
being held by the Obama administration
wasn't given medical care was Rachel
crying about
I don't remember Rachel shedding tears
about that she didn't recount that to us
at our family reunion did she the Barack
Obama administration admitted sicced
admitted 16 admitted ms-13 members into
the country so we let them all just come
right in these these were people who we
knew had affiliation with ms-13 he
placed over a dozen kids in the custody
of human traffickers known human
traffickers why because he didn't
perform a background check the Obama
administration didn't perform a
background check what else oh yes so
there have been a handful of cases in
the Trump administration relatively a
handful of cases we're talking about a
couple thousand kids who are being held
because what else are we going to do
with them are we gonna we can't send
them right back immediately we can't let
them into the country unaccompanied then
given amnesty are allowed to break our
laws and fly our laws under Obama there
were over 100,000 cases between 2010 and
2016 immigrant cases that separated
families 100,000 not a tear from Rachel
Maddow isn't that strange in 2014 alone
by the way this is a really funny irony
because now he's saying these kids are
coming in and they're holding them
they're encouraging kids to come in and
they're going to be a hold elde in 2014
alone around 70,000 unaccompanied minors
crossed into the United States illegally
70,000 and and the left then it's very
hard to keep track of these things the
left bend was encouraging it they said
yeah come on over here yeah then you
Detention Center yeah come on over now
it's the worst crime in the history of
the country why because they don't
really believe it they don't really
believe it there if they really believed
it Rachel Maddow would have really been
crying there and more more to the point
she would have cried in in 2014 when
Barack Obama was doing these exact same
things we I want to get to what this
speaks to because this is the essential
aspect of our time Chesterton's fence
this is the Reformers the reformers who
yell do something do something tear this
down change this do something right
before we get to Chesterton's friends
and make Chesterton's fence ten feet
higher folks we got to bring on Derek we
have a good guest he has a book out that
really is a proper timing the book is
called outrage incorporated how the
liberal mob ruined science journalism
and Hollywood Derek thank you for being
here thanks for having me Michael yeah I
couldn't have picked the timing any
better but I'm still jealous of your
book I I wish I had thought that for the
research you did it had to have started
when you were a teen the research
started from when I was a little boy
I've been researching that book all of
my life the timing there was very well
too because it was something about early
2017 really made people understand the
important thesis in my book reasons to
vote for Democrats a comprehensive guide
but I could you know listen I always
knew you're a gentleman now I know that
you're a scholar as well this book talks
about the outrage that we're seeing
pouring out I mean my my leftist years
tumblr has been overflowing for the last
few days everybody is outraged all the
time when did it start
why did it story well there's always
been an element of it on the fringe of
the left they've just been the angry
left ready to take to the streets but
the main part of the party the
establishment of the party kind of kept
them at bay now they're the base so
they've got a ready-made a table of
unwashed mutants ready to march at a
moment's notice the the day after Trump
was inaugurated they took to the streets
he hadn't done anything but they knew he
had to be opposed two weeks later they
marched for science he hadn't done
anything but they knew he was going to
grow everything it is an amazing feat of
marketing to sit there and tell somebody
be angry all the time and have it work I
wish I had that ability but the the
reason
behind it is if you keep people angry or
you keep people scared Michael you're
not thinking rationally you've been mad
at your remote controller you've stubbed
your toe on your coffee table or
something and you you've cursed or
thrown something in a fit of anger
you're not thinking rationally you
wouldn't normally do that but if you're
angry or you're not thinking and that is
what the left has to do to keep their
base motivated because otherwise what do
they offer in come November Bernie
Sanders crazy a job for everybody well
we've got basically full employment so
he's miss right on that we already have
it now for everybody
Medicare for everybody well we just
found out that in 2026 that's going
bankrupt so you know if somebody's
willing to give you a first-class ticket
on the Titanic you're still going to hit
the iceberg so they've got to keep
people from thinking rationally and it's
been on display it this week
I love the Democrats running down there
saying Donald Trump is using these poor
sweet nourishing children as human props
while they're making sure that they're
framed properly in front of these poor
sweet nourishing children that they're
using as human props it it's evil it's
crass it's ballsy but it's not
surprising in the least I'm just jealous
that they're so good at it I wish I
could be that good at it oh well I want
to get to the doomsday cult and where
this crazy outrage might spring from I
have a thesis on it front based on what
I read in your book but before that you
know we're talking about all of these
happy children at the border I want to
talk about another way to make children
happy and that would be little bits
how's that for a segue little bits an
award-winning platform of easy to use
electronic building blocks for creating
inventions large and small that's the
best segment we've ever done right we
got it I want an award for that it is
really cool it is great so I've got this
for my little nephew when I got this
they that little bit sent me their cool
droid kit
you know there's Star Wars droid kit and
so they send it over here and I'm so
coming I'm gonna give it to my little
nephew that'll be a nice thing all of
the 30 year olds at the Daily wire jump
on top of me they're like you know
leeches trying to get this toy to play
with themselves it is very cool it is a
super cool toy the complete Droid kid
has six bits 20 droid parts three
sticker sheets in a free app the app has
step-by-step instructions video
tutorials it's got drive mode force mode
self nav 2000 authentic
sounds from the Star Wars films and Yuka
and you build your own droid so you can
reconfigure it in ways to create
brand-new droids kids learn to control
electronics with code in missions this
requires a smart device so you get to
use it do it from your phone or your
mobile device it's really cool I was
into Star Wars as a kid if this thing
had been around there's no question this
would be the number one toy yet and I
think that's the reason it keeps winning
awards you got the toy Association's
2018 toy of the year for your kids and
inspire invention it is so so good visit
little bits dot-com slash Noel's canno
wles
get $10 off a droid inventor kit don't
say I never did nothing for you little
bits comm slash Noel's ko wles
ten bucks off a droid adventure kit this
is the gift to get I always worry you
know with my nephews or nieces what am I
gonna get them I don't you know I'm not
like totally in the kid culture these
days
what am I gonna get them for a gift for
Christmas or any holiday get them this
little bit's the complete droid kit and
save some money
little bits comm slash Noel's so Derek
you know on this outrage question where
it all came from very early on in the
book you say this is firstworldproblems
that there is a sociological function
that when people have it too good they
need something to complain about and
then you also talk about the doomsday
cult of global warming and I've always
noticed the environmentalist movement
really launched into full form after the
fall of the Berlin Wall
after the Cold War ended after our
actual existential threat ended the left
just made one up it just invented one
out of whole cloth Oh
is all of this outrage just an aspect
and a consequence of our luxury and our
decadent society a large part of it is
when the Berlin Wall fell in the Soviet
Union went away the left lost
they were basically rooting for that
side so they needed to come up with
another way to oppose capitalism and
individual liberty and that was a
ready-made one there with the
environment what better way to scare the
crap out of somebody than to say you're
destroying the planet we are destroying
the planet we must now cede our Liberty
our property to the government in order
to save the entire
planet and of course if you remember the
90s in the early 2000s Al Gore was
running around going those ten years ten
years or it's too late if we don't do
something now it'll be too late well
that came and went and we haven't I'm in
New York I didn't take a gondola to my
hotel
we are not flooded the storms that we
were promised didn't happen they weren't
more frequent they weren't more powerful
so rather than what a normal human being
would do when something like that goes
wrong and reflect like hey maybe I was
wrong about this
they decided smartly from a diabolical
point of view to extend the time frame
it used to be ten-year predictions now
its 100-year predictions you Michael
Knowles if you predict it come Friday
the world will end and you get a bunch
of followers Saturday morning you're
gonna have some explaining to do but if
you decide no no in a hundred years the
world will end well you can't prove that
but more importantly you can't disprove
that and now if you look at the climate
change studies they are 100-year
predictions they talk about the year
2100 because nobody will be around to
recognize that they were full of it that
they were lied to but we must act now of
course the answer is always now whether
it was climate global cooling in the 50s
which was a ready for Dan was writing
about it in the 50s or global warming in
the 80s and 90s or just generic climate
change we always must act now in the
solution ironically was always the same
very curious no matter what the problem
was the solution was the same which
would cause a normal person to go that's
weird
when the problem was the exact opposite
the solution was the same so they again
they have to scare the hell out of you
or something like that a question like
that might occur to you yeah I love that
that's the argument for socialism now
the earth is getting too cold
therefore we need socialism the earth is
getting too warm therefore we need
socialism the earth is either changing
or staying the same
therefore we need socialism it's always
big big government has failed what we
need is bigger government right
obviously the solution it's insane but
if you're not a thinking person it makes
sense you know and that is this is the
Chesterton's fence thing we're gonna be
talking about that later in the show
that they just say we have to do
something now in 350 million years the
earth is
going to have two degrees higher
temperatures therefore we need to do
something do something do something
right the big promoters of this hysteria
the big outrage vendors are the
journalists quote-unquote from the
mainstream media or the journalists I
think there are three options are they
stupid hysterical or cynical I guess
they're not all mutually exclusive but
do they really believe what they're
selling do they really buy their own
product it's impossible to get into
somebody's head no matter how much room
there is in there and there's a lot of
empty space in these journalists heads
but I would say it's a little from all
three of those columns
it's the in-crowd when you're rolling in
the circles I live in Washington DC when
you're rolling in those circles and
you're at the cocktail parties
there is no dissent it is like having a
sea of bobbleheads on the dashboard of
your car going down a dirt road they're
all just going up and down like yes yes
yes yes yes so when you go to some place
look every four years they go to Iowa
all these journals they pat themselves
on the back as heroes because they went
to a diner in Iowa and had a talk with a
real human being
then they immediately go back to New
York or DC take a Silkwood shower
delouse and then live for four years
telling everybody about how their trip
to the zoo in Iowa visiting real people
to the elite from the coast the country
in the middle the middle of the country
is nothing but the place their chemical
toilets jettison on their private jets
as they go out to LA that's a good it's
a good metaphor for what they do in
their commentary and punditry that's the
mentality out there they believe they
are the smartest and the best and the
brightest because they have a little
badge that hangs on their lapel with
their picture on it that gets them into
places the general public can't go
having worked in that business I can
tell you you don't have to be a genius
you don't have to be a rocket scientist
to get a media credential it doesn't
imbue you with any special knowledge and
as we see every last night Rachel Maddow
crying on television I wonder how many
onions they had to cut to make that
happen
mr. I take some offense because I am her
but you're absolutely right she has a
tone she had two settings off and
sarcastic and suddenly they upgraded her
to 3.0 and they added tear yes good I
don't know that's good I heard the new
version has an emojis too so that
because it's an upgrade you know the
you're so right to about that talking
about it for the next three or four
years they say I was in Ohio they write
about it like Thomas Friedman every
single Thomas Friedman column you know I
was on a bus in Beirut and I talked to
somebody that's how they write about
Ohio and I'm like it's Jack Kerouac on
the road they come back and they publish
their journals like they've cured cancer
when all they did was talk to a real
human being who doesn't have an advanced
degree in 1940's bisexual polar bear
studies real people with real jobs who
get dirt under their nails you know and
don't have a manicurist to get it out
that's right now do you that you cite in
the book later on in the book you cite
at Lyndsey's stone she was that girl at
Arlington Cemetery and she took a
picture in front of the Unknown Soldier
and it said please be quiet or don't
yell or something and she was flipping
the bird and pretending to yell she
wasn't really yelling you know this
picture went on Facebook people got a
little angry and then the media blew it
up they said oh there's outrage even
though there was only outrage after
after they posted the picture right this
girl she lost her job she got death
threats rape threats all of this I mean
you really feel bad for the girl by the
end of the episode it is there any end
to this or we mean it just seems so mean
like people are just out to get each
other and there's no grace and there's
no forgiveness
do you see our culture turning a corner
or is there only gonna get worse I think
it's only gonna get worse because I
don't know how to dial it back honestly
I'm not saying that to be funny I for it
to be turned down on the left we saw
yesterday the Secretary of Homeland
Security chased out of a restaurant
because of who she is an angry mob came
in and chanted her out of it it would
take democratic leadership not
tolerating that from their base but with
an election around the corner there's no
way they can't not tolerate that from
their base because
bass is all they have on a slow news day
an average person can be destroyed by an
angry journalist bored and looking for a
scalp right on a regular news day they
all suffer from Trump Tourette's they
mentioned the president's name and that
Nazi Hitler they just immediately
freaked out
mention Ronald Reagan to a committed
leftist the man's been dead for a decade
more than a decade been out of the White
House almost 30 years and they will go
off as if he had just run over their dog
and is right in their driveway they do
not forget I've written a column about
this they do not forgive it's they don't
want to defeat you they want to destroy
you yeah that is how they work and when
you're dead they're still going to come
after you if you make the only sin and
liberal them and that is thinking wrong
and disagreeing with them that's exactly
right that's such a good point I gotta
let you go I've taken up enough of your
time
but it's such a good point and the book
is so so fun to read it's right that's
really a great read beginning earth will
be destroyed in three thousand years if
you don't buy this book today so keep
that in mind it will don't have that
blood on your hands people outrage ink
how the liberal mob ruined science
journalism in Hollywood by Derek hunter
Derek thank you for being here thank you
so unless that actually is the perfect
segue because it is the question of do
something yell scream we have to do
something
this is Chesterton's fence and this is
Chesterton's fence getting ten feet
higher under the barack obama
administration because that's all the
democrats who they say they see these
kids at the border even though they've
been coming through for years and years
and years they're now the trump
administration is actually following the
law enforcing the law that was supported
by Democrats and and some Republicans
alike and they say just whatever do
something other than this do something
and do something is what people who
don't know what to do say that's a
that's you remember that kid from
Broward County David Hogg he it's hard
to forget because he's on CNN every 15
minutes he would say we have to do
something and said what do you want to
do he'd say something how about
something have you guys considered doing
something because that's what I suggest
we do this is a right now Donald Trump
is talking
a possible executive order to stop these
separations the executive order would
violate the law it would violate the
load be in violation of federal law and
then what then what's gonna happen do
you think the Democrats will say okay
good job Trump no they're gonna yell at
them for violating the law they're like
there is no dealing with these people
seriously they are not honest brokers
they're not being honest actors here
Rachel Maddow wasn't crying when Obama
did far worse to these same people than
Donald Trump is doing it is all just a
scheme and people shouldn't fall in for
it on the doing something Chesterton's
fence gestured GK Chesterton the great
writer who we reference on the show all
the time he he put this very well he
said quote in the matter of reforming
things as distinct from deforming them
there is one plain and simple principle
a principle which will probably be
called a paradox there exists in such a
case a certain institution or law let us
say for the sake of simplicity a fence
or gate erected across a road the more
modern type of reformer goes gaily up to
it and says I don't see the use of this
let us clear it away to which the more
intelligent type of reformer will do
well to answer if you don't see the use
of it I certainly won't let you clear it
away go away and think then when you
come back and tell me that you do see
the use of it I may allow you to destroy
it
Chesterton's fence people who go up they
say this must be crazy I don't
understand why this law exists I don't
understand why this rule exists well if
you don't then I'm certainly not gonna
let you change it because you don't
understand anything right I'll only let
you change it you can tell me why it
exists and why it should be changed and
how changing it will make it better this
is the issue of this policy because the
alternative is putting kids in jail
that's the alternative to this policy
what would you rather do would you
rather put kids in jail and with their
parents but they're in jail indefinitely
little toddlers in jail indefinitely or
would you rather have them in facilities
that are run by HHS and have their
parents in jail just like in America
when a when a parent goes to jail for
committing any crime in America the kids
are somewhere else the kids don't go to
jail with their parents the parents rob
a bank the kids don't go to jail with
them right so you could do that or the
old
which the democrats want is to just let
the kids go free and let the parents go
free with them and stop prosecuting
parents that's what they really really
want this I'm getting there's breaking
news now I sound like I'm Rachel Maddow
Donald Trump President Trump did sign
the order to end family separation we're
gonna have to parse how exactly that
went this is being reported by the LA
Times I was gonna do it I think we all
knew this was coming it just was such
bad optics but it's not a smart move to
play into the Democrats demands here
it's not good to take their premises I
will have to parse and see exactly what
this executive order does because there
are only going to be more problems down
the road
if this violates the law which it is
hard to imagine that it won't the
Democrats are not gonna let up on this
but there were beyond the executive
order that's not really the main issue
here beyond the executive order there
are three bills being proposed three
pieces of legislation to address this
issue because the executive order is
just a patch right they'll say okay
we're gonna stop enforcing the law well
it's gonna come from that then you're
gonna GL kids or you're gonna let the
kit or the parents go either way you're
gonna have trouble three bills being
proposed Senator Dianne Feinstein Paul
Ryan and Ted Cruz to Senate bills one
one from Speaker of the House Paul Ryan
the Feinstein bill bans the separation
of families that's its violation of the
law possibly like this executive order
this was articulated very well by a
congressional intern the other day as
president Trump was walking in here it
is
[Music]
that's one of the most articulate
Democrats I've heard from Congress
that's a congressional intern yelling as
the president walk through the Capitol
that's basically what Dianne Feinstein's
bill means it's just you know screw you
mr. president
then the Paul Ryan bill allows the kids
to be jailed from more than 20 days so
they won't be separated but then you go
you've got kids basically in jail I
don't I don't know that that's a great
solution then there's the cruise bill
the cruise bill is pretty good because
the cruise bill addresses the
immigration issue it doubles the number
of immigration judges and expedites
proceedings it expedites deportation so
that it won't be an issue to separate
the kids because it'll all be done
before the statutory minimum or the
statutory maximum of how long kids can
be held in custody that seems like a
great idea of course Senate Democrats
are gonna say no because they don't
actually want to fix the problem they
just want to demagogue there's some bad
news here there is some bad news for the
culture is really I don't know how the
GOP is gonna get get past this because
of this big issue the GOP has lost a
fake Republican a fake Republican
strategist here his Steve Schmidt he was
the head of the McCain campaign for
president here it is here is what GOP
strategist Steve Schmidt has to say I
said they don't feel guilty about being
a Republican I've always been a
Republican my father is his father was
the whole family's Republican family I
voted for Dwight Eisenhower the first
time I ever voted I voted for Nixon the
last time
but when we come to senator Goldwater
now it seems to me we're up against a
very different kind of a man this man
scuse me now maybe I'm wrong
a friend of mine has said to me listen
just because a man sounds a little
irresponsible during a campaign doesn't
mean he's going to act irresponsibly you
know that theory that the White House
makes the man I don't buy that I mean
when the head of the Ku Klux Klan when
all these weird groups come out in favor
of the candidate of my party either
they're not Republican sir I'm not I
thought about just not voting in this
election just staying home but you can't
do that because that's that's saying you
you don't care who wins and and I do
care I think my party made a bad mistake
in San Francisco and I'm gonna have to
vote against that mistake on the 3rd of
November vote for President Johnson on
November 3rd the stakes are too high for
you to stay home oh that wasn't Steve
Schmidt that was the same trick that
Democrats have been playing on
Republicans for ever including all the
way back in the LBJ election so Steve
Schmidt what are we gonna do I mean what
is the GOP gonna do we have just lost
these chief strategist for the McCain
for president campaign I mean this we
have just lost one of the worst GOP
strategists ever who ran a campaign that
literally suspended itself just for no
reason
that campaign that made it an important
point to say nice things about Barack
Obama the opponent that that campaign
that guy what does the GOP gonna do how
are we ever going to keep losing
elections if we don't have Steve Schmidt
now we're gonna have to start winning
elections that'll be terrible that'll
cut against this squishy strategy that
the GOP has embraced at various times
Steve Sherman he's a total squish he he
would frequently invoke that that phrase
country over party which is a
meaningless phrase by the way they
always say that when people want to
attack their own political party it's
usually just Republicans who do this
they say country over party and
if that's an actual dichotomy that's not
a dichotomy the reason I'm a Republican
is because the Republican agenda is
better for the country much better than
the Democratic Enda so I'm a Republican
for my country I choose my party because
of my country there is no world in which
you have a dichotomy between your party
in your country it just means you're not
a member of that party I don't say
country over democrat party I'm a
Republicans country over the party that
I'm not in okay right duh that's why
it's a party that's why you're in that
party so Steve Schmidt I mean you
actually could trace his tweet storm
leaving the GOP point by point to that
video that LBJ put out the Democrat
campaign for president he he follows an
almost point by point Steve Steve
Schmidt by the way Steve Schmidt is a
guy he's such a swish that he actually
wrote an amicus brief to the Supreme
Court on the gay marriage issue because
he wanted the Supreme Court by judicial
Fiat to radically redefined marriage
that's how radical de sky is but he came
out he tweeted quote 29 years and nine
months ago I registered to vote and
became a member of the Republican Party
founded in 1854 to oppose slavery and
stand for the dignity of human life
today I renounce my membership in the
party it's the party of Trump it is
corrupt indecent and immoral with the
exception of a few governor's like Baker
Hogan and Kasich okay kids keep going it
is filled with feckless cowards who
disgrace and honor the legacies of the
party's greatest leaders the child's
separation policy which was signed under
President Bush and which Barack Obama
enforced and you never talked about it
then is connected to the worst abuses of
humanity in our history it's connected
by the same evil that separated families
during slavery and dislocated tribes and
broke up Native American families I'm
sorry hold on just one second I have to
pop open my tumblr just collect mmm good
that's good I'll go on it is immoral and
must be repudiated our country's in
trouble our politics are badly broken
the first step to a season of renewal in
our land is in the absolute and utter
repudiation of Trump and his violin a
blurs by electing Democratic majorities
and there it is
there it is folks this
been building for a very long time for
Steve Schmidt he's been waiting for the
opportunity to just publicly endorse a
bunch of Democrats he goes on who cares
what he says right it's all just
ridiculous nonsense I ego you know he
invokes Ronald Reagan blah blah blah
they've disgraced our country blah blah
blah vote for Democrats that's what he
says even you I do want to point out he
uses the word Fidelity's he says this
independent voter will be aligned with
the only party left in America that
stands for what is right and decent and
remains fidelity to our Republic he
could have said faithful which is like
the right word to use there but
Fidelity's because he's so grandiose is
so flowery okay that's fine that's fine
Steve I hope I hope we can make it
without you I hope this is gonna be
really frustrating if we have to start
winning campaigns now instead of losing
them all the time and apologizing to our
opponents but Bob I see yet this always
happens the squishes always leave it's
been going on for a very long time the
hysteria knows no bounds I will explain
by the way exactly the answer you need
to give whenever Democrats or squishy
Republicans say stuff like this or they
accused Trump of being a Nazi or
whatever I'm gonna explain exactly your
response but I got a say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube we only got a
little bit here left if you're on
Facebook or YouTube go over to Daley
wire.com if you're a daily wire
subscriber thank you very much you
helped us keep the lights on you keep my
cup filled with salty and delicious
leftist tears and always an armful of
coffe fa so go there right now it's ten
bucks a month one hundred dollars for an
annual membership you get me you get the
Andrew Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get to ask questions in
the mail bag get your mailbag questions
and we'll answer them on Thursday none
of that matters you need this tumbler
you need it now you need it like three
days ago actually so I'm probably just
talking to a bunch of floating cadavers
right now with their face book open you
need the Declan wire left as dears
tumblr go to daily wire calm to protect
you your property and your family we'll
be right back with the answer to all of
those Nazi accusers we'll be right back
okay so we saw Steve Schmidt's little
temper tantrum this happens with other
fake Republicans too it's all the
Republicans who go on MSNBC and all they
do is either lose campaigns or no one's
ever heard of them until they went on
MSNBC like Anna Navarro you know Anna
Navarro has never done anything to help
the Republican Party ever and but then
she goes on MSNBC and she's the
Republican strategist which is
Republican strategist is another way of
saying somebody who was here who would
come on the show somebody who hit who
can talk on camera there right that's
what that's all that means
so but you've heard the hysteria ginned
up like crazy especially over this
immigration thing they say Trump is a
Nazi and this is what Nazis do and he's
Hitler and he's a Nazi a Vox
this is a headline from Vox Jeff
Sessions tries to beat back Nazi
comparisons gets literally everything
wrong from The Guardian Melania Trump's
former immigration lawyer compares
border crisis to Nazi Germany and slave
trade and then not to be outdone here's
Newsweek ice director uses Nazi defense
to claim border policy is not like
Hitler regime we're just following
orders okay I get the sense that all
these people these major outlets these
are not fringe people right these are
major outlets on the Left they're all
comparing Donald Trump and his
administration to Hitler and the Nazis
this raises a serious question because
there were only two options here one
there these people are being hysterical
and disingenuous and nobody actually
thinks that Donald Trump is Hitler or
his administration or Nazis that's one
option or they actually think that these
guys are Nazis and in order to fight
against the Nazis they're perfectly
willing to tweet a little bit and wear
pink hats imagine these people I mean
actually imagine this for a second if
you thought that Hitler had just taken
power in the country and then you didn't
do anything about it and then you just
thought oh yeah you actually thought
that there was a regime in power now
that's about to start murdering millions
and millions of people overtaking our
neighbors invading Canada and Mexico and
Poland I don't know
and deporting you know people and
murdering people and genocide and all of
these awful horrendous evil things and
then you said in response to that I'm
going to tweet and nothing else that's
all I'm gonna do those people would be
work those people would be worse than
Hitler right they would be Vichy
Americans they would be people what's
the line they say all that it takes for
evil to prevail us for good men to do
nothing
they're people who were doing less than
nothing right hey look it's Hitler if
you know the thought experiment if you
could kill baby Hitler would you kill
him there like they see adult Hitler
he's like walking right by the mic Wow
Hey look baby Hitler well but that I
mean it's so so obviously they're
disingenuous nobody thinks this guy's
actually Hitler but you should point out
to them if you actually think he's
Hitler you're abetting Nazis you're
allow it you're just standing idly by
while the Nazis wreak havoc and
destruction and evil on the world so
good job fishy
good job fishy American but obviously
that's not the case people are being
totally disingenuous and that nobody
actually thinks that which is why people
are ignoring the mainstream media in the
in the few minutes before we have to go
here I'll just I will just point that
out everything is getting better in this
country and that's why they're being so
hysterical even you know I I feel like
this could be a daily segment things
that are getting better today because
every day there's something new we have
out now Millennials are finally moving
out of their parents house so during the
Obama era there's kept living with their
parents at greater and greater numbers
in 2017 that number finally started to
tick down so thirty one point five
percent of Millennials are currently
living with their parents that number is
pretty high I think the standard number
of people in that age group living with
parents is about 28% that number is
pretty high but it finally ticked down
from 32 percent so the number is finally
turning why I don't because the country
is getting better and people are making
more money and people are finally more
employed we have virtually zero
unemployment right now we have more open
jobs than people looking for jobs we and
by the way the in defense of the
Millennials they do have a trillion and
a half dollars of student loan debt and
they got basically nothing for it they
got these awful fake education degrees
you know they've they got these degrees
but they didn't learn anything in
college and certainly no useful skills
and not
in serious and liberal arts or liberal
education for the Millennials to the
wages that they're earning are lower
than their parents were earning at the
same age they're actually significantly
lower like 20% lower in 2013 the the
average millennial earnings were about
$40,000 a little bit more boomers their
parents earned inflation adjusted over
50,000 at that same age so they actually
do have a little tough but finally after
the Obama malaise the economy is doing
better and they're moving out of their
parents house that's very good
Millennials are the largest generation
in the workforce right now 35 percent so
we should hope that they can afford
their own apartment right now it just
came out from the National Association
of Manufacturers over 95 percent of
manufacturers are optimistic about the
future they say things are going well
and things are getting better that it's
the highest number ever recorded from
that Association record-breaking numbers
why because things are going well
disability claims are way down this
one's amazing because when the economy
is bad all of a sudden people start to
get disabled that's really weird you
know you say oh gosh how did that did
that economy come crashing down on you
and broke your back or something and
people file these bogus disability
claims and they start getting on the
government dole because they can't get
any work and they don't really want to
work and everything's just boring and
sad two years ago from the Social
Security disability fund analysts said
that that fund would run out by 2023
which is coming up pretty close because
there were so many people on it during
the Obama economy now the analysts are
changing their tune they're saying it
won't be depleted until 2032 and
actually we might have more good news it
might even be even later because people
aren't using it because they're getting
work they're getting jobs the country is
doing better and what's happening Rachel
Maddow is crying
what does Rachel Maddow crying about is
she crying about the kids being detained
because their parents their criminal
parents entered the country illegally
and subjected them to this horrible
situation no she's not crying about that
because then she would have been crying
about it when it was much worse in 2014
under Obama she's not crying about that
at all Rachel Maddow is crying because
things are going so so well and her side
is losing because of it because her side
offered nothing but failure and malaise
and division and America has finally
turned a corner things are going well
and what's gonna happen your tumblr is
gonna fill up so kodály wired I'll make
sure you have it I'll just be here
sipping on this for the rest of the day
get your mailbag questions in for
Thursday until tomorrow I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Dahl show
I'll see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you